hello lealan Jones Boone
I'm de Bruin this is the report and I've
got to make favorite all-star
panelists Whitney Mixter recker lick are
with me
those get those good local don't have a
real
military movie right now just incredible
ah right here we go let's get to it you
probably heard
about McDonald's new mascot its kinda
knew it at least new here in the United
States his name is happy
but look at Happy this guy's happy that
either scary freak and I've got that's
real
when I saw this birth I thought it was
one of those stories that you see
there you go no that can't possibly real
cat that looks scary to me I
happy according to the Gallup press
releases about bringing more fun and
excitement to keep meals including
eating wholesome food like
low but younger great now we can we can
come back at
happy just when you look at Happy the do
you feel happy
what is the emotion that happy brings
out your well
I will say this: in my personal hell
thousand the
characters will be charging toward me
with for eld happy playing on repeat
yeah you know that they had
make that an armed will never be cool
and that will never be healthy they're
trying to give it new thing where they
like
I've seen some ads were they trying to
appeal to hipsters recently
IP in this this looks like some graphic
designer in college with in their room
in my put together this like very
amateur looking
graphic tell me if not it doesn't you
know
symbolize anything that is that cool
impression
whatever right so I want to get to the
cool and fresh thing but first just
on happy himself here's the thing I
don't think
do this I've been happy I've never been
that happened
you never never never been remotely and
happy that Happy Meal
I am and yet there isn't the the they're
replacing all the food they they
giving you like apple wedges in the
Happy Meal and maybe that
X amount of sugar is a put some
over-the-top I'm
baby I i do it doesn't look like
something professor yet looks like
clipart the heck it looks like something
a comedy show
would make in order to make fine
have a Happy Meal type massacre yet is
there something deeply psychological
going on with metallic that they have to
do something that bad it over the top
because it exactly where your point is
which is they're trying to be something
they're not so they cared
automatically make something that would
be or I really bring anything
the word deep and psychological I cannot
be upset if you think that %uh
both why that I am United trying to give
them the benefit of the doubt here
no I don't think they deserve any
benefits the dow yeah
definitely the doubt given as much as
possible it's crazy that
eyeballs on that thing the back that I
mean look at it
its eyes are permanently pretty little
after having back up there
it's very scary it has an enormous
Hathaway
show itself is very in writing I feel
like I can cuz they have been there for
hours our right like they've got tix
yeah
treatment rated the veneer T the eyes
peeled back
the skinny this would be a it's Bruce
Jenner yeah
it kinda there's no and I the elbows
like eat happy meals and you will have
no
bones in your are you no bond than just
an incredibly large
torso yeah it's just so this this kind
of gives me positive reinforcement that
people have
caught on to McDonalds cuz when I was
that when I was a kid
we would eat Happy Meals all the time
because that was just what you did in
the eighties he and we have
have we have birthdays parties are there
member the birthday breakfast at
McDonalds would
pancakes I good my incredible yeah
n/an/a now people are on to them and
they have to resort to these very
strange
things and it's almost like someone who
is the agent break rock was like what a
kid like Abu near
give them one use a computer so that's
what it is when we started this by
saying that we all are on to the
the thing that they're doing now so it
has to be over the top they show with
hipsters
everyone everyone's always been in their
commercials also would you be going to
McDonalds generally the people I
that beer they're not that happy at all
that directly
okay but they they they just keep
doubling down liked it to push the image
yet I i think i mean you know you never
wanna run into someone
you know Anna MacDonald its true like it
not a yeah
gathering but not the but iraq a
fast food at all but those commercials
were all those hip good-looking people
like sending fries to the girl down
there that a liar
I'm to iran you know I'm totally in this
and use infrared
I'm you don't know where is the old
school party around nope
where credit's where murder Hamburglar
yet but the Hamburglar
yeah I like shooting heroin in a corner
somewhere right now like they've given
up on life
you know you never tire burning down a
lot at everything so offensive these
days the grimmest I'm sure would offend
Purple People what a hamburger whatever
I love to eat at McDonald's all the time
I the shape agreement
you know when I remind me correct that
the Hamburglar
you know criminals guys you realize that
the comment is going to say we're
elitist bastards for making fun at
mcdonnell and they would be correct
there okay yeah you know i i applaud me
downs recent attempts to like put
lettuce and things but now there's like
a green lettuce now as opposed to like
the iceberg version they used to have
great and they offer a grill a grilled
chicken
right of the photograph for grilled
chicken branding to be pressed into
other cut otherwise picked me yeah why
don't they just do the honest thing in
just 30
met with their cause I think it why
don't they just double down on that
instead of the lie that somehow the
healthier good pre-war
buy nor happy why don't they get a quick
we know this is fast food like
they're not getting anybody will
honestly be nice I would go to make down
out more often
if there was like just like them
overweight guy I really sad and
depressed I'm given up on life
but I'm an annual me a Big Mac one more
time I believe yeah
like it you know right yeah I also like
it when you're in the Olympics comes
around
all the Olympians are spotted by
McDonalds anything if those are the only
people who can
eat McDonalds yet because those are the
people who can eat 5,000 calories a day
and still maintain a busy cuz they're
working out all the time that's what you
know I remember the old remember the
Larry Bird the michael jordan Capri on
the crap out of that were in everything
that there are they like these guys
would never eat McDonalds during the
playoffs because it's not like the
libyans where they have to keep being
just for whatever
right I like their don't take the money
from now that but that's a whole other
story yeah
let's move on let's talk some politics
President Obama have your to this guy
and he basically it out this week that
he's gonna be doing even more
executive orders is pretty much because
congressional Republicans refuse to work
with him or do anything
for the government so we have a
statement from damn Piper who is 0
bombers
senior adviser given this dynamic and
what he's talking about is how the
republicans refuse to work with
President Obama president Obama has only
one option to use every outing is a
party to unilaterally improve
economically carry
next week as congressional Republicans
spend their energy on yet another part
of an investigation
will be picking up the pace on executive
actions to help the economy
we have many more executive actions the
common everyday the president has charge
estimate looking for additional ways
to expand opportunity so he's talking
about the bank I think hearing that the
republicans are gonna do
I am I'm a little completed by this
because on one hand I think
that the republicans have been awful
they don't want to work with the guy and
is becoming the lame duck every day gets
closer to
to leaving on the other hand I don't
like one branch of government
sorta superseding what its power is
buddy their great things though Obama
thing with our the executive order
he's created 11 national monuments I
really think that that's the kind of
things yes the paper in there so is
likely the name are all just me being
unilaterally overstepping my bounds
I'm do it what to do he's created up
more than almost three times as many
national monuments George W Bush
said he did not know he's being very
effective in doing things like making it
even goes the cactus
in a in a place is protective will never
be never be taken apart but I i get a
with executive actions and I know what
like
that's okay any something's happening
the and its fine and
a it all comes down to like what is the
date overall dynamic
and you know if the Republicans are as
dedicated to stopping him from doing
things they say they are well then
they'll kinda find a way to overrule is
executive
at Borders yeah why don't think they can
overrule the executive order
counteracting pass something in order to
get that to happen but in the meantime
just go for it and do it
yeah do you really should he just do
this cuz he sorta has no choice or I'd
that bad in line was living and you know
these monument that is putting up
I must say that it interesting how you
kind of playing into the american people
would be
monuments because he's kind of like look
at this thing and while you're out here
let me talk about carbon emissions
because that's what you play and let me
know I
I mean you're getting people's attention
you're like a look at the giant
saying it's shiny and at the monument
that you love and while you're here I'm
gonna talk about various issues and
hopefully paper that and you know it so
I got to give them credit for that and I
agree with you though I don't
I don't feel like I don't want to see
this become timetable dictatorship of
course but
you know I think I think politics kinda
like this political whack-a-mole
happens you know it's like it people
don't do things are you taking executive
orders and then
connect guys gonna come and in the you
know be able to overturn the things that
he put in
so it it's just gonna happen but at that
these are headed down to tell about so
that nothing ever changed rather than
being fed you know franklin roosevelt
which it with considered but many in 10
the most popular president about time in
the amount
executive orders that he made what Obama
has done that would like his afternoon
tea time I have executive or
author you know right so they do go
crazy about later brought that up
because they go crazy constantly on Fox
News about executive order
and you're right he hasn't done as many
other ways the other thing is that even
as many
as George Bush George W about equal but
you know george bush made some pretty
hefty executive order
have been you know that will like them
tho etheridge or
presidential you know be able to hide
things within the president to you now
iraq yeah yeah things like that so
the so if this was a Republican right
now republican president you really
didn't like in the democrats were
stonewalling his all they would you be
more pissed about this
let me know and do it now not really you
being intellectually
army alexi on it I don't you know when
at it
I'm one of those people really get up in
arms when it comes to like running
against each other
I like that more I think I fall in line
with most americans when it comes to
that end
and in terms of whack-a-mole like if you
need something big happens
there now say I can that specific thing
with terrible
but I don't think the average person is
you know and rightfully because they
have so much else to worry about
paying enough attention for this to
really kinda
come to the forefront above their daily
lives so I kinda fall into that I have
way too much house was to like
I so it's me hear that how much farther
how much at this is just
drama it's just sort of this endless
drama that they're replaying over and
over
and nobody believes what they're saying
they're just doubling down a party thing
the money
don't know it's all drama and there's
always like 1 it new movie that people
are using
you know there's always when when you
get to gridlock you have to do something
different
and in this situation the gridlock is
happening and so
the president is trying to do something
different to get around it
and just as when they were going head to
head trying to get things passed through
congress
people try different things that make
this is something he said well I can
actually do this
so I'm gonna go forward and do it I feel
like the republicans are gonna pouting
on the playground right now I'm here
local while you're doing that
I'm gonna go handle business so you
can't be mad there you go
I like the action that you gave me a big
big big game people can you please do
not bring
your guy and the integer poll a that's
what they're requesting after a buncha
guys carried
military-style assault rifle into which
a poll a
franchise in Dallas Texas they were
promoting their open carry laws because
you're allowed to if you have a gun
you're allowed to openly exhibited and
bring it around into public spaces
but you probably would just prefer you
not do that they even
issued a statement display a firearms in
a restaurant is now create an
environment that is potentially
intimidating
or uncomfortable for many of our
customers a question when I and
to go on and say nope so please don't
bring guns into trouble they will give
you that
guacamole but we're gonna charge extra
there with a big big point that
yeah illegal or extra yet like I know if
you've got a moment at Clovelly it's not
break the American actor i've the gods I
have and it's going to be at a premium
so these people they're bringing the
guns they're these are so right for
these are not just him not just a
handgun at a fast food joint is urs or
Apple
but they have a right to do it so before
we get jokingly be about them should we
defend their right
to bring their weapons I mean
you now I'm slightly intimidated by
saying you know I don't know
summit gonna come out like me now pull
their weapons I makers
good lord reading all the comments
underneath his article
there is a IR demand people really want
that
second-amendment amendment upheld do you
the
I'm you know I think that there needs to
be some paper parameters that though you
know it's not like
they can I just pushed like my Canon in
through the door and the like
just sayin that me you know I'm here
dick openly Carey
I'd like a burrito or yeah one for me
and one for my cat and the hat and i got
really bad
for the you know burrito rappers that
need to come out
and you calmly asked Billy Bob to like
put their assault weapon back in the
track like it just doesn't seem like a
fair
pairing but yes so if you an integer
holy and there was two guys sitting
there with assault rifles
on the table what would you do or I went
to Costa Rica to a pizza hut near the
guy outside with an assault rifle
and it freaked me the hell out but he
was just that Garrard
Yahoo to the garden he had a sorrowful I
get it I mean
yes neither me it's tough when
it's like a the way in which you display
your right
is really scary yet you know that's what
everyone's afraid I have
and I think nations solve this all
by having different kinds of chipotle
ace there's a Chipotle a
where you can have guns and then there's
chip police were you can
only have guns and news like a algun
Chipotle a like a battle royale Chipotle
button well I like the normal chipper
like they have to have these ones that
have
only everyone has a gun and then the
normal Chipotle ace where they have that
trademark Chipotle a knife fight every
so often right so basically in the south
that's where the gun ones are the night
fights where compared to others liked
the guns in our kind the city they feel
like people
you know I just I just want I you know
it that I i want them to be able to have
their right on display but
I mean its weird way where you can put
your guests are able in the car outside
I mean he won it with you want someone
steal a nap
Yahoo part or chrome though that when we
have these two
talks about guns that the comment
section always everyone demanding their
right that they immediately
you can even talk about that and say
that maybe you shouldn't be allowed to
bring its alright paul
into Tripoli be immediately take that as
they're coming for I can quickly
they can review your service if you have
no shirt no got back Glee but
hit your carrier thought were able with
no shirt no shoes maybe they'll have to
allow UN now I don't know
yeah I mean I think that there needs to
be a balanced
hat which is you can can it carry a
concealed weapon which would make sense
you know you have it on you still why do
you need to light the lamp around I just
don't understand
yeah hoping right at the end of the day
as well yeah he'll show cause its orbit
yeah that issue for me at least yeah
do you
I would be you it will be there be this
is really a HIV nah
know that my brain is mighty yeah
I think we've been got a good is there
any bring a helmet
i DIII as long as I can still get
diarrhea chip berlet
which it happens all the time really I
love Triple yeah hi I have to prove
anything I just swallowed like that have
the right city I support live like the
Four Seasons
yeah I think they'll I don't know if you
think so spices and I seventy so spicy
try the mild sockets now the always get
like a little tiny thing how a pain you
in there later based on by eyder
whatever Tripoli days will help with
your order okay we'll go from there
we're not gonna besmirch to Paul II
Michelle
okay let's move on America might
actually be ready for a gay
president some people say we've had a
gay president or two but yeah
a new poll is showing that we might
actually be ready for this is by pew
Research Center for the people in press
let's take a look
the majority american 66 percent say it
wouldn't matter for presidential
candidate was gay
or lesbian night 27 percent say they
would be
less likely to support a gay or lesbian
candidate while
5 percent would be more likely and in
2007 nearly
have said they would be less likely to
vote for a gay well as being handed
so doesn't really surprise me that much
a lot a good case that has been
happening just last week what we get
that one of these activist judges
they took down a pennsylvania is now
going to gay marriage a roaring in
the so get good gay things are happening
what you have a segment called gay stuff
good
day stuff good games that you could be
the token straight guy
yeah to be president yeah
so no the ambassador for the lesbian
community at
you must feel good about this you can
narrow you can now be breast I didn't
actually
I actually planned this segment to take
a moment to talk to the american people
about my run
2014 I now I feel really excited about
that
a I like them gave no specifics about
your rather lead to me and that puts me
and it's gonna be good
it's gonna be a now I think I think is
very telling you where we're coming in
this country I think we've made huge
steps
will meet forward really in the past
couple years and I think now people are
realizing it doesn't matter
who you are you're probably gonna fuck
up the hey you know
like yeah I get it now we've had plenty
of straight Presidents
and they still manage to fuck yes good
hello
you know i mean well right now a better
issue your apology when i'ma get great
yeah I think that's a good I think that
the joke that's why I have any other
president yeah
here no he never going to get nothing
what about you
that can be there know that my campaign
slogan has
yeah we will get jacked it here
yeah ok that go every yeah
oh man I'm by dealing with so I think
it's obviously great right
course it is so yes well maybe we'll
have a gay president probably within our
lifetimes fantastic
do you think the biggest hurdle actually
will be the the public display of
affection
cuz that's still the part that is not
shown for gay people even though there's
been a huge
but you know it's really hot her to
watch most presidents be a for sure
like I mean I think Obama but there is
one that can I had likens flag with him
played a first lady yet but you know
George W Bush
that was where did like an awkward I'm
like what did their sec
way you remember the horrible al al gore
cast America got with al gore remember
that go ago it was that that was two
thousand yeah that one where it was like
listen I'm a row bob the actual
hell yeah paper down I
and he did and it was just so grows long
yeah and it was just strange
and I get that I mean and and theirs is
I don't think that anyone is being
edna's but those public displays of
affection regardless of gender like
I think those are still kinda creepy
know me and I think everyone find I can
a middle ground where it's like a
tasteless by then
it's okay then it stable but it's how
it's hard to find it headed to have a
one-third goes overboard you can enter
yes sorry we're agreed that that's
pretty gross no matter who is giving
will be easier to have
a gay email or lesbian
first at my gut feeling is you we
probably have a lesbian purrs
what I am Hillary Clinton yeah I want to
go I'm yesterday
a.m. night it might be easier but then
where attacking
where of not only electing our first
woman but should be realized in hey
again I'm ready rather than
yeah now I think it's possible I mean I
don't know I'm one hand they feel like
people will be more active
you know vote for man i dont no I mean
historically it's been the case
but I think people film more
uncomfortable seeing that kind of
rate I just feel like I committee
abrasions are uncomfortable having a gay
leader
back whom yeah I would always with the
shower I was up here
way where are we as well Hollywood where
we go yeah I'm a in a Justin Bieber
that I'll on that note that get okay let
I
everyone gave to get cold enough and
Russia just got great called
it there it I'm really really go all
right sir Neil deGrasse Tyson you
probably know he's become sort of
American scientists you doing cosmos on
box right now which is really really
fantastic if you're not watching
you should be watching it I so he
brought up on his radio show
on star talk radio that basically we
shouldn't be giving
equal time to climate change deniers as
we're giving to actual scientists who
believe in climate change
he was talking to CNN's miles o'brien
take a listen
accuracy in journalism that leads to
with that what's this phrase
is it fair and balanced I had to ask
mild
was with Bayern balance movement that
we've been hearing about the check it
out
on some stories have one-sided is
represented by CAA ninety-five percent
in the scientific community the world
is it fair in a story about climate
change which I'm obviously talking about
I'm
to do this classic journalistic
Convention No
equal time for both sides this is a huge
mistake I think virginia's $295 per cent
and then
is a5 percent you get a person from that
five percent
right now get 50 percent return is ax
serving the truth
I would submit to you not is matter fact
that is
beating obfuscation that is actually
perpetuating
Amir dare I say online all right now I
am completely with you miles o'brien the
here that they give you what cosmos
every animated section cosmos is a
and and I'm not saying that any of these
people write it every animated sections
about out
this guy said something that no one
believed and no one would listen to him
and had they not listen to and they you
know continue not to listen to this one
percent
then we would never have gravity or
whatever the hell
so they're something fundamentally wrong
about the logic here
yes I get that left side are you on
their own
argument against them climbing tonight
there's a better argument
against letting idiots speak yeah you
know that and then this one
this the logic here does it doesn't play
out because like every
scientific idea that has ever been
adopted on a large scale started with a
small scale so you can't go with the 95
aspect of it you know a hundred percent
of people thought the world was flat
until they prove that wrong so that's
that's just that a logical thing I think
to graft I think about also be watch
this show they had the cosmos you get
that thing like
some people had picked on all their
lives and when they get to be cool
may just are cool near the graft I could
still interested people
like he is now like meeting out his
vengeance on Polk
and he gets like he takes like way too
long on the cosmos to talk about
the the 88 climate deniers like rapa
girl
did not agree with you there is like a
five percent like rubbing in their nose
que
thing I actually I I don't mind it I am
what do you think should
when we talk about climate change or
what CNN at all the networks basically
do what happens they give fifty fifty no
matter what is based in science
ninety-seven percent as I disagree thing
to get a guy should get 50 percent
yet I mean fair and balanced turn on
them and
but are we talking like does that mean
that FAC
just doesn't exist that the news
reporting to mr. height because I feel
like
it I do they provide a 50-50 Fairmount
I'm sure they're not giving fifty per
cent break you
I'm right by the numbers but I doubt
they're getting fifty percent to the
climate change I don't know I mean I i
mean in general journal helmet if he's
talking about journalism
but me baith on you know in equal time
and
in in perspective viewpoint or accuracy
and I just
don't feel as though you know faction
even be a this thing in this world that
they gave
and but its and actually picking a fight
they actually just it the fact that they
just came out and said actually said
that climate change is real
that shit a hundred percent go ahead go
take that last
3 percent and yes prove that the
Antarctic
is currently melting into ourselves
right now there's a piece for the
antarctic that's like what do they say
it like 20 times the size of Manhattan
right just fell off and it's melting is
nothing we can do in miami's gonna
disappear
so how do we honestly have a debate
about is there any detail is there any
purpose of having a debate
I think I agree that be proportion of
time
spent talking like up people who know
what they're talking about people who
don't know what they're talking about I
get that the proportion is
of and they should adjust who is allowed
to speak for how long
but I think we need to go the other way
up what Neil deGrasse Tyson is a
I think we need to let the idiots speak
longer have because that's the most
entertaining thing for me to give that
ninety-five percent of the time
because it entertaining because it's so
stupid and then you left for an idiot
talk for long enough and they put their
foot in their mouth and no
expose has to get back to that sort of
the theory that you know Bill Nye
the Science Guy did the debate with the
guy from the creation thing and he
believes that Jesus was riding a
dinosaur basically and a lot of people
that are they were saying well he just
let him hang themselves so in
that year like John Oliver did that
thing where he let
he brought on 97 yes I am here have to
debate against
the re non where weirdo jesus's
she should leave a scientist B president
we're just talking about we could maybe
a gay president do you think maybe it's
time that we had like a lot but I am NOT
yeah if a site is that with that at the
very nature yeah
yeah no really couldn't you regulate
aside his rise and like someone who's
actually based in fact
and I in arrested in
money or immersion yeah and I think that
that would be a great idea
I'm going to take the next couple months
to go get my doctor ai back
by iraq do you want to tell the camera
again like it yet but I will be studying
very hard for the next four months don't
worry I'll be back
twgdna TV your for scientific lesbian
cousin
I are we go or more for you let's talk
about net neutrality we've been doing it
every week because this is the most
under-reported story in the mainstream
news they are dropping the ball surprise
surprise
the FCC put net neutrality net
neutrality but basically the principal
that everyone had equal access to the
Internet in the Internet Service
Providers couldn't produce your internet
based on the company's that they were
are connected with
that is no longer even though Obama said
he was born in Cali the appointed
telecom lobbyist who was also campaign
bundler
and the guy flip net neutrality you can
check that out if you don't believe me
I the Sunlight Foundation publish a
series ago are
graft explaining lobbyist spending
on net neutrality and I think it pretty
much explains the whole him
so giant companies the internet
company's like a rise in
AT&T and Comcast the big boys
they basically the red what you're
seeing their these are reports that they
issued through their lobbyist that were
against
net neutrality and then somehow net
neutrality
got flipped and if that's not enough
approve for you about what's going on
here that this is just about money
but look at the next one this is the
total lobbying expenditures at the top
20 organizations with the most
reports mentioning that neutrality and
yeah you're against
net neutrality you spent ship load of
mine and
on a report lobbying politicians and
then as we talk about a couple weeks ago
there was a senate Commission on net
neutrality and literally
every senator on the Commission had
taken money
from Comcast and the only one who fought
against the
without breaking because you're taking
the least amount of money so if you
don't know what's going on here
it's pretty obvious at this point I I'm
gonna keep talking about net neutrality
even like like the ship has sailed in
its really sad
a what should we do for people that
exist in this online space
and if the last best Egypt freedom in
this break-in country Heights love they
them the report people putting out
report after report like
if someone gives me out with a report I
hate that
I that working that should not be
working
what is it with politicians they love
report I was thinking the same thing
like that ever get to the politician te
llego get an apartment that you can't
get no I hope this report give me
another there are you
yeah for their hard work for him I gotta
that report was a report yeah I let the
bottom to the tape sponsored by the bad
guy I just think I think it's like I'll
report cool where that money again
yeah so it's so frustrating i'd its
there should be the problem with so
pressuring is the money that they're
using to buy this
influence comes from people who are
using our service coming from viewers
like you
viewers like you who are losing who are
basically paying
to pay more later that show whole
frustrate yeah
and I honestly don't know what the
solution is there is
no real so immediate but it works the
same way any resource works
where the my you know the people who
have who are controlling how it's doled
out
and the scarcity a bit have all the
control yet because what are we gonna do
like I mean there's no word
there's no I can't even have like you
know a bunny ears on my aunt n anymore
in
you know so time-warner and makes me
have a box inside my house
right to literally what what was free
the free to get the basic channels are
like ABC Fox where that was free
and then they went digital so you can't
not have just free television what is
public
service you can even get that yeah its
it it's one of the most pressing things
because
it's such a complicated process that is
unfolding not before our very eyes some
were talking very deep away
and that we can't even get to under it's
like my reckon credit report like I
don't even know how that works but it's
affecting my life
in a yeah but it was banned this is that
happen I mean this
typeof thing and we going on and every
facet a big business
and the Internet is the biggest you know
a channeler
information and commerce now and it was
just a matter of time where things are
eat regulated by a.m. kinda monopolized
by the big guys
you know and you're right we don't
understand how did this thing where
I don't know located within a series of
tubes yeah here like
rather than go they the AOL running man
was just being a visible days are
are we gonna look back at this time and
I've asked this before when we done this
but we look back at this order two
thousand
the just about now as the as the glory
days of the Internet like 10 years from
now when it all really controlled and
Prada old
and you're paying per whatever purview
her
that are we look back know how it was
pretty good back then it was pretty good
and evil playing not busy this
immediately be
now that you've got bored with me but
thank you got it but it's very
yes this is the Golden Age right now
because right
essentially what we had in terms of you
know the way people the kind kind in the
people want to enjoy
typically is like video-content right
and or at least there you wanna read it
on your own but if you compare it to the
way cable you still
it cable works if there's tears the
cable so if you want to watch all that
but that whole model F cable is
disappearing right and so did
that Telcom still want a tiered system
so they can charge you for more and
what's happening now is our ability to
get
around all that all these people who are
like listen I just want to sign up for
Hulu and Netflix
and have it on my watch are totally
winning the pace
so much less every month and right now
the telecom realizing that
and they want to still have that model
in there trying to you know get it that
way and they have all this money from
the old system
and they're just going to go for yeah
and if you don't think the Old Testament
our country screwed up there was this
report issued this week about how our
internet america is like
one of the worst for industrialized
nations or not even getting good service
in the first place but I guess we don't
even know it cuz when was last time you
guys are in Korea South Korea
check I would like north korea a well
yeah Hardwell on that note I hope you
learn a little something here maybe
gallo dahmer may be laughed a little bit
the I will let you to pimp yourselves
out
I'm what director and I will be your
future president
doctor wit you make the I
and aside from that time on the Twitter
Whitney Mixter lay in store when the
mixed relay and you could take my bike
at
WWW dot Whitney inside a dot com thanks
for the debbie is
debe de vida here practicing W
high winds up my name is George W Bush
are many
rhetoric and I'm not running for
president because I know for a fact that
could not do the job
I you think see me at Twitter dot com
slash
Brett Erlich and you can watch me on pop
trigger
on the Young Turks network on YouTube
also we do it on
who once a week you can do that yeah at
least until
the internet crashes and they take a
thought okay with the record